oh don't mind me just occupying the
Skycar park this week
London's again being gridlocked by the
loopy middle-class doomsday cult
extinction rebellion but what these
Krusty's don't get is that their
protests aren't achieving anything or
persuading anyone they're just paying
off decent people who resent being
called earth murderers and who couldn't
get to hospital or to work this week
extinction rebellion screamed that their
defenders of the planet yet they have no
credible solution to save it and their
predictions of hellfire if co2 emissions
aren't scrapped by 2025 or hysterical
Cobblers we all know the planets in
trouble X are what your only solution
seems to be banning meat cars and plays
and dancing to trans music and singing
stupid songs you're a joke
instead of knocking the government how
about getting off your idle backsides
and infiltrating it climate change
doesn't need direct action it needs
political action through the mainstream
system laws taxes incentives campaign
for policies that work with people's
lives
we forest our lands put taxes on their
travel but then all that smacks of hard
work and there's a lot less exciting
than partying on the planet so you admit
that there's a serious problem and for
my entire life I've heard how we're not
doing enough we're not doing enough
we're not doing enough and we haven't
been doing enough I mean I had to move
out of London last year because having
moved there for eight months the air
pollution for somebody with asthma I
couldn't even exercise just was
intolerable for me we have air pollution
problems there's a there's a town in it
called Fairborn which is gonna be the
first village in the UK to actually have
climate refugees because there because
of rising sea levels destroying the town
there is the fact that a lot one of the
reasons why we have such a a a refugee
crisis in general is because certain
parts of the world are becoming simply
uninhabitable what our extinction
rebellion doing to stop all that they're
making the point that the politicians
need to get off their buttons the
politicians have
do you know what's happening in this
country already there since 1994 carbon
emissions could be cut by 44%
we can't fur just 1% of the world's
global emissions we the thames is
cleaner than is read in the last 20
years
the politicians have started their work
and all extinction rebellion do is tell
you what we can't do
they set impossible targets like getting
getting rid of all carbon emissions by
2025 it's impossible we don't have the
technology they're not getting rid of
them carbon neutral carbon zero okay
zero carbon it's impossible to do rich
you must know that and they must know
that and yet they don't they don't read
the science the science there they
ignore the science they have their truth
and if you don't believe their truth
it's a problem okay deny it but they've
got very specific aims they want the
government to declare a climate change
emergency and because they've dismissed
the one that trees a mayor called
because it's been symbolic and pretty
much non-binding when they've declared
that that's wood that's not doing
something they want they want the
government after he said binding targets
and they want greenhouse gases to be
reduced in that zero by 2025 and they
want the government to create and be led
by the decisions of a citizen's assembly
do you agree with this target of 2025 I
think that yeah I think that we should
definitely aim for that and set binding
targets to achieve so which airports are
you going to shut I'm saying that you
need to invest in it in the technology
I'm ask you a question which airports
you're gonna shut if that if the
technology doesn't exist to achieve
carbon neutral by 2025 the government's
responsibility to invest any in little
say six or seven years away which
airports are you going to close I'm not
saying what do you have to because I
though you're not gonna reach target
you're gonna have to virtually close
down at Earth F stop cars going on the
road you have to stop their trouble you
have to stop cars
you have to stop ships everything that's
good let's ban vision because there's
man me too let's all become vegan yes
let's become vegan you know the thing is
their argument is lost because they've
not properly made it this is not a
serious green group at all Greenpeace is
a serious green group there they're
fighting and campaigning to change
things this group just shouts death and
destruction and doesn't actually
pressure groups who've always had a look
around in politics as they should this
is an effective pressure group in some
ways I mean what I suspect if they keep
going they become less than
effective because you know when you do
something the first time it has an
impact I think it did have an impact
when you're doing it a 20th time and
they're 2 weeks it doesn't have an equal
time people trying to get to work people
taxi drivers can't work so people who
are not earning very much money being
driven further into austerity people
like you complain about this government
austerity extension rebellions forcing
people into austerity we come back to
the debate we had a couple of weeks ago
the trouble is democracy doesn't fit
what you maybe need to do that actually
exactly the point you're making about
airports you're making about cars yeah
people don't want to do that if I want
to actually continue they don't mind
being sympathetic but they want to
continue to fly they want to continue to
drive the gut as I do and that's what
I'm saying the green argument is not
being made if so it's very very well
Caroline Lucas standing up and saying
take fewer place but if you want to take
a family on holiday you're gonna go on a
holiday with a plane and this is the
party this is the disconnect for
rational people in knowing what it is
they have to do and people like
extinction rebellion aren't telling them
what to do and that's the problem we're
gonna see one of the so-called
uncooperative Krusty's in a minute but I
want to stick up for what they're doing
I mean I think that it took 30 years for
the first foot to get from the first
meeting of the International Panel on
Climate Change to get to the Paris
Accords which were signed up by most
industrialized countries - the US they
do 30 years for the for the world to get
its act together on an issue that
Margaret Thatcher was actually one of
the first world leaders to identify you
know the goal is rolling now extinct
making any difference - yes they are
happened at about when they gave each MP
a tree to signify that actually there
are little things that people can do if
we've planted X billion trees we would
combat but we know that the screen size
gap yes but that's something you can do
with that close if we could pursue that
the argument of fehmi's pursuing
factories will closed factories were
closed we haven't thought this through
uncooperative Krusty before you get into
your rant
are you willing to be arrested
yes well because unless we do something
dramatic and make them a lot of trouble
this terrible climate change with us is
going to continue exactly we need to
raise the profile we need government to
listen and whatever age whatever sex
agenda we need to be our tune so I
decided to lose it's a it's only two
weeks I think it's not impacting on you
trying to get to work people go to work
in hospitals people can't get on buses
it's the second time this year for two
weeks huge I think they're doing I'm
afraid is they are there it's a popular
court but they're making it unpopular
because they're so they're so
inconvenience of people and when I was
actually recording that outside a member
of the public harassed me because he
thought I was a real person
he thought I was blocking a road to the
sky he arrests me he swore at me he
called an idiot that's what those
protesters do you said they're going
work the wrong way you suggested that
they should go they should go into
Parliament our democratic system isn't
built for that it looked the Greens have
a similar vote of the amount of support
in the UK as they do across Europe yet
in the European Parliament they have
over 60 MEP s in the in the UK as he
said we have Carolyn's representation
now if we have reports representation in
this country then yes maybe they cut
because it's and a chance is getting
into Parliament but right now they don't
for was in arguing for another time can
I just say this argument about blocking
bridges access hospitals this is what
was discussed on Sky News well I think
it's about this understanding of the
wider perspective and we have people on
the bridges you can have conversations
that people are trying to get there and
as potential of you know if people
really really need to get there but
letting them throw possibly in that
conversation we're really really
we don't want to be doing it but we're
running out of time and this is what we
have to do right now I understand people
are going to be adversely impacted and
some people are going to be impacted
more than others but the change that is
coming what is going to happen is going
to there is no escape for anybody the
famine the grief the war is going to
impact on all of us
I'm afraid it's complete hysteria
completely we just say global cyber
right coming up as we speak
okay yes it's time we moved on I don't
think we're going to crack